hello and thank you for joining us
for the advancing science spatial
genomics data analysis scientific track
i'm jason reeves senior scientist in the
translational sciences group advanced
technology hosting our program today
joining me are several leaders in the
field driving forward spatial omics
research
including chris mason from wheel cornell
medical center
where he's an associate professor and
co-director of the world quant
initiative for quantitative prediction
dr christina curtis associate professor
and co-director of the molecular tumor
board at stanford university cancer
institute
dr omar barakhtar group leader for the
cellular genetics
group at the sanger institute and he
will be joined during our discussion by
his
graduate student alexander the avezidas
and finally we'll be joined by dr
giannis blatros
who is the co-director of the
bioinformatics program at the cancer
research institute
for beth israel deaconess medical center
during this track each presenter will
present their experiences
with geomets dsp and their institutions
perspectives and approach to spatial
biology and data analysis
this will be followed by a roundtable
discussion with all speakers
to gain greater insight on data
standards as well as the infrastructure
and resources
required to execute on a new wave of
technological development within the
growing
owings ecosystem as a quick housekeeping
note
any of the if any questions arise during
the presentation we encourage you to
submit them to the q a box below
we will respond back with your questions
via email
please join me in welcoming all of our
presenters
and i would like to hand it over first
to our first speaker chris mason
you so much for the introduction it's
really a pleasure to be here with a
really uh
extraordinary group of investigators and
clinicians here so i will
jump right into some of the work we've
been doing for shotgun transcriptome and
spatial profiling
of code 19 and what we see what the
virus is doing
in the body and around the body and how
it manifests basically so
uh basically i'll start with a quick
preview of some work that we've put in a
preprint in a paper that's in review
of taking the first 735 patients that
came through the doors at while cornell
medicine and new york presbyterian
and did rt pcr lamp as well as total
rna-seq
to look at the differences between the
coveted positive and negative patients
and this
this will set the stage for what we want
to look for is a deeper dive in some of
the geomets data that i'll show you here
today
but basically we wanted a variety of
molecular methods to
do a dive on what's happening when we
see the infection can we pull out viral
sequences
and perform phylogenetic and genetic
analysis of these
variants and see where they've come from
indeed um we could actually see
basically taking all these fragments of
rna align them to the reference genome
compared to the wuhan strain
and we can see here that we can
reconstruct some of the phylogeny and
evolutionary history of the virus
and so a lot of the different variants
are showing up in some of the new york
city samples
uh from the bulk rna seek that data
alone
this also let us look at the presence of
co-infection so if you look
uh here we can actually see whether
there was low medium or high levels of
star cb2
and if there wasn't on the right you can
see this sort of pink section where we
could pick up other uh
respiratory and rna viruses as well and
on the left you can see in some cases
pneumonia is also present so we can see
from the total rna seek data we can
discern the infection broadly
we could also look at differentially
expressed genes or degs and see up
regulated and orange and down regulated
here in purple
you know from this bulk rna seq data you
know profile interferon stimulated genes
and generally
inflammation networks that if you look
from a pathway perspective
would group into things that are
familiar such as reactive interferon
signaling
viral antiviral response but some that
were surprising such as
you know olfactory signaling pathway
here in the lower right or hemoglobin
and iron regulation
indicating some of the really cardiac
and hemological disruptions from this
virus
which were really surprising we also
built up uh tools
uh to look at cytokine interferon
signaling and make these heat maps for
any select set of genes and actually
one of the things i want to quickly
highlight today is that we also have an
online interface where you can make
and take some of these same data and
make your own heat maps and explore our
data
it's a website we put up at just
covajeans.wild.corner.edu which is for
anyone to explore the data we want to
make this as open resource as possible
for anyone to play with these data as
well as some of the isoform
characterizations
and so we used some of these data and
actually already published one paper
just looking for example
at complement factor pathways which you
can see some of the same kind of
disruptions
uh from these cov2 infections so
what what's interesting is you know this
these some of these has been you know
this has been published
in a variety of contexts and pre-prints
some of our own in the past four or five
months
but what's really missing from this is
you know we can see a lot of the
disruption in the body we know that
there are
really challenges that the body has to
confront during infection
but what's been missing of course is a
more granular and even
a spatial characterization of what
happened during the infection so we
actually
have been collaborating with nanostring
uh as actually we just got our
geomex installed right before covet hit
new york city so it was a
good timing also collaborate with them
have some samples run out of west
and what's uh you know i think is as
most people will cover in this webinar
is that this gives you an ability to use
barely um high plexi mixtures of
reagents
that have a uv photocapable linker with
the dna oligonucleotide
as well as rna reagents with an
oligo-labeled probe that let you get the
spatial information using the genomic
system
to look at say ffp slides which is
actually very important for the covid19
autopsy samples which i'll show you
today because we needed to put them in
ffp because they were still infectious
if we didn't actually put them in
ffp or some sort of shield or trisol so
other other systems where you can't use
ffp treated samples uh
basically were intractable in the early
days unless you had a bsl3 lab
so what we've been using is the genomic
system we're actually going to
illuminate and uv cleave some of those
regions of interest or rois or areas of
interest or aois
and then we can actually these are
there's a slide just based on the
geomics you can see we can then
look and see the expression levels of
what's present in different regions
across these tissues so what we did is
as our alluded to
you know use the stain slides with the
oligoconjugate antibodies
look for rois and then also wanted to do
spatial profiling
as well as cleaving putting them into
plates and then also sequencing them
on next seek and then characterizing
them essentially with accounts uh per
gene
uh across the different regions and so
you know this is the workflow basically
is dsp library prep is pretty standard
on a nexique 550
and then sequencing in counts of
analytes per gene which i'll show you
some of this data today
and this was again was a very
collaborative effort because we did this
between two different sites so we
did out some zoom calls with nanostring
and went over some of the logistics
we want to look at regions of interest
from a large airway vascular zone
alveoli
and also macrophage in infiltrated
tissues
from autopsy patients from the first 35
patients that would get autopsies done
at new york presbyterian to get a sense
of the tropism of the virus for example
where is it going in the body and then
what is the virus doing at a spatial
level uh during the infection
to better learn about you know the virus
and also hopefully to figure out ways to
then combat it
so what we did is uh you know con
conferred and then selected these rois
in collaboration
between uh uh actually rob schwartz here
at cornell
and also my lab also allen who's at
cornell and then the austrians group out
west
and basically pick 285 areas of interest
uh look maybe
filtered for anything samples that had
low reads or uh problematic uniqueness
criteria
and then basically had about 282 aois
that were left and if they had
fewer than 250 nuclei those were removed
or those that had fewer than 50 genes
identified so kind of
some basic quality control of these
sections we got from the lvli large
airways
and some other parts of the sort of
samples we got from the autopsy
and you can see down here on the left
the number of genes detected per aoi
was anywhere from 500 to a thousand or
in some cases 1500
and the number of you know sort of uh
what we see for the scan for the
different
samples a lot of them we're getting from
the alveoli sections you can see here on
the right but
but overall seeing that range of detect
number of genes per aoi
and we could actually pick up here is of
the you know about over 1800 genes in
total we got about 18 11 from the
uh the cta essay which is a
comprehensive a cancer transcriptome
atlas
assay and also we did look at some viral
genes spiking to look for covid
and again also did some qc filtering
here on the data as well you can see uh
just for basic qc
what's interesting is when we look at
the samples that had coveted versus flu
versus normal
and acute respiratory disester number
ards we can see that the normal and flu
samples are clustering pretty well in
the avli whereas
there was some more variegation and
heterogeneity of covalent near the esses
at least based on these samples and then
when we looked to
see if we could recapitulate some of the
same pathways that we observed in bulk
rna seq data
we could indeed see some of the cytokine
signaling that we saw in the immune
system as well as interleukin
4 and 13 basically alpha and gamma
signaling from interleukin
response to signaling pathways which
show up actually in some of these
samples for the gene set enrichment the
other interesting thing you know and so
this is something you can get from bulk
rna seq data so it was good to see some
of these gene set enrichment analysis or
gsas
again recapitulating these data what was
really exciting i think was be able to
tease out the abundances of different
samples
whether covet samples or flu or normal
or ards
and see things like this huge burst of
macrophages in some of the code patients
or for example
you know other variations of disruptions
of what you see from neutrophils uh
would be you know compared to say normal
samples
uh which are actually the normal lungs
that we got here were from
lung transplant patients where as you
can imagine when you trans you know
basically do a organ transplant between
people of different sizes some people's
lungs are bigger than others
so you have to shave them off like at a
deli and these are what we use for
normal samples so it's a
interesting thing about normal but
clearly some of the code samples are
very very different
then to validate these we use the rna
scope as a method to characterize this
with a different hybridization method
um and this basically was looking at the
coded fluid normal samples
to look for the presence of h2 basically
receptors h2 tempers ii
and also the presence of the virus
itself and so from these samples
again we looked at cova patients flu and
then one normal some preliminary data c
was detectable the other targets were
detectable at very low levels are not
detected
and to lay this out for you visually we
can see for example uh h2 expression
um and also in some cases presence of
the virus at low levels from the rna
scope versus genomics data
and we can see at the height you know
temperatures too was in some cases
very visible uh but not as much present
in alveoli for example so we could see
some heterogeneity in the expression as
expected at a spatial level
for these different markers and you can
also see in some cases the virus
present with the levels there's one case
that actually knew based on rtpcr didn't
have much virus and again we didn't
really see it here
as well but we could see plenty of
tempers too in both the large airway and
the alveoli
as another example of seeing variation
variation of tempers ii
in the large airway and alveoli
especially here at the sort of rim of
some of the alveoli so
again underscoring some of the
heterogeneity that can be and we do see
in some of the coded patients as well as
the way they deconflued the cellular
sort of infiltration and sort of damage
that's occurring
in the lungs so in a quick summary uh
this is you know we could see
differential
clustering of expression where the
cuvette near this group seems to be more
heterogeneity
we can see tempers too definitely highly
expressed in large airways but you know
variable among coveted samples and also
uh the virus variable within the lungs
especially later in infection we're less
likely to see the virus present in the
lungs
and also we could see a single cell
deconvolution methods you could see
for example implicating macrophages or
neutrophils that would be uh much more
pronounced than the cobit patients and i
want to thank
nana string as als as well as uh thank
everyone in the lab who made this
possible and
a great group and really inspiring team
who we often like to go throw axes and
drink beer at least back in the
pre-covered days when we could go do
this and we look forward to doing this
again sometime soon
and thanks of course the funding from
the nih also collaborations from
uh world quantum citadel as well as of
course uh string and thanks everyone
in the lab specifically and thank you so
much for your time
great so i'm really pleased to share
some of the recent work that we've done
using the nanostring geomics platform
to understand how the tumor immune
microenvironment changes through therapy
particularly in the context of
her2-positive breast cancer
so we've had a long-standing interest in
understanding how tumors evolved through
therapy and
in this particular context we felt that
um
a study of the changes in the tumor
microenvironment during preoperative or
neoadjuvant therapy
uh would be particularly informative and
we sought to address this question in
her2-positive disease where um routinely
speaking
patients are treated with standard of
care neoadjuvant therapy
in this case we turn to a clinical trial
cohort where we were able to obtain
pre-treatment baseline tissue biopsies
prior to the administration of any
therapy
subsequently these patients underwent
one cycle of her2 targeted therapy with
either
trastuzumab and or lapatinib and they
were then
at that point obtained a second on
treatment run in biopsy
and finally these patients went on to um
obtain six cycles of her2 targeted
therapy
prior to surgery um to determine whether
they had
achieved a pathologic complete response
or not and so
the neoadjuvant setting really provides
a rich opportunity to obtain high
quality tissue
in this case we focused on profiling
formal and fixed paraffin embedded
material from some 56 patients
split into a discovery and validation
cohort from the trio b07 clinical trial
and um using the nanostring geomets dsp
platform
uh we used a phenotypic enrichment
strategy where we profiled a minimum
of four different regions of interest
across
each time point for each patient and
using pan-cytokeratin
based enrichment strategy we were able
to
specifically enrich for tumor and rich
regions
and this has tremendous value as we
think about profiling
relatively infiltrated breast tumor
cells but also allows us to go after the
immune population that's particularly
infiltrated the tumor
and separately we can obtain the
inverted mask area
focusing in on the tumor
microenvironment
region by taking um the the inversion of
this and so
we profiled a total of 4x 43 annolates
per
section and to give you a sense for
these data what i'm showing here
is individual patients labeled along the
x-axis where we can see whether they
achieved a pathologic complete response
in red or if they didn't we've also
indicated their er
and pm50 receptor status and then shown
along the y-axis
each dot represents a region of interest
where we're showing the protein
expression levels for her2 in blue
and cd45 in red and we can of course
look at these rois and the extent of
heterogeneity
across each sample so just looking at
the baseline time point we actually
don't see
really dramatic differences between
these markers and that was in fact true
of
virtually all markers we examine in
contrast when we compare the
pre-treatment time point to the
on treatment time point looking at all
tumor markers we see a pretty dramatic
increase
in the extent of heterogeneity with her2
the target of these therapeutic agents
being the most dramatic but numerous
other
tumor markers also increased and
somewhat surprisingly we also see a
dramatic increase
in the heterogeneity of immune markers
from the pre-treatment to
on treatment time point
so when we look at what's taking place
overall in these
um individual tumors what what we can
see is in fact by looking at a volcano
plot where we're showing the
change in expression in the pan side of
keratin and rich regions
of the um run-in versus baseline time
point
and then plot the negative log 10 fdr
adjusted p-value what we can see is that
a variety of tumor markers in particular
her2 but
all of its downstream targets are really
dramatically decreased on treatment
and in fact we see an enrichment and up
regulation
in a variety of immune markers and and
just looking at a correlation plot we
see that in fact many of the tumor
markers are very tightly correlated and
anti-correlated with the immune markers
so um motivated by the fact that we saw
pretty dramatic differences we then
sought to stratify the discovery cohort
by responders those that achieved
apaciar and those that did not
and what you can appreciate from this
plot is that really the vast majority of
the signal is being driven by the
responders
again we see that dramatic reduction in
virtue signaling
um by the on treatment time point and
this is just after one cycle of targeted
therapy
and a really dramatic increase in immune
markers and in contrast this is
simply really not very evident in the
non-responders
and so we were also interested in and to
what extent this was reflected in
bulk gene expression data and what you
can see here i'm using match
patient samples is in fact that the
signal is really dramatically attenuated
um there is some signal in the in the
pcr cases but it is
um much to a much lower level and
presumably this reflects the attenuation
due to the admix population
but also keep in mind that we had
performed a pan ck enrichment to really
focus in on that population using dsp
and
that's one of the great values of this
approach
so i also want to just turn to the
pan cytokeratin adjacent regions where
we can really profile the tumor
immune micro environment that surrounds
the tumor and to point out that
um using this phenotypic enrichment
strategy we can actually now
ask which immune markers are enriched
in the infiltrated tumors so higher in
the pan cytokeratin in rich regions
versus those that are instead perhaps
higher in the surrounding
tumor excluded regions and what we'll
see here is that
there's a number of immune suppressive
markers pdl1 ida 1 that are
increased in the pan cytokeratin and
rich regions and in fact we see
evidence for an enrichment of t cell
markers that seem to be excluded from
the tumor cell
so we can actually ask how these
patterns change not
just at the pre-treatment time point but
on treatment and by the time of surgery
and what we can appreciate from this is
actually
that there seems to be an influx of t
cells and and this trend towards
exclusion decreases
over time and so collectively um this
by using dsp we're really able to
address
some unprecedented questions in the
context of the temporal changes in the
tumor immune microenvironment
through therapy um and so with that i'd
like to thank the many people who have
contributed his work in particular
catherine america who read it and it was
really a very rich
collaboration with our colleagues at
nanastrang
and so with that i'd like to um
hand the baton over to omar barcarati
from the sanger institute
thank you christina for the introduction
and it's a pleasure to join you all
today
um so um i'm a group leader at the
sanger institute and today i'll tell you
about how we use the whole
transcriptome atlasing version of
nanostring
that allows you to measure the
expression of 18 000 genes
on the developing human brain to
understand
the human brain tissue architecture
so in general our lab is interested in
studying uh
the structure function and diseases of
the human nervous system and one of
our focus points is the different
cell types their distributions and their
fates in various neurodevelopmental
energy neurodegenerative disorders
when we started this collaboration with
the nanostring you're actually quite
excited to take the wta assay
that effectively allows you to do
transcription-wide measurements
and actually apply it to the human fetal
brain to be able to distinguish
different cell types
so there are many things that i can tell
you about the structure of the human
fetal brain but one of the major reasons
that we used it for our study
is that it shows a really striking
spatial arrangement of different cell
types
the brain structure that we focus on is
the human cerebral cortex or also called
the neocortex
and when you look at it in the
developing fetal brain you basically see
that it's split into
two different areas first as you can see
on the diagram in the middle
you have different kinds of neural stem
cells and progenitors shown in green red
and blue
and germinal centers and
second you have differentiating neurons
and
glial cells that are found in the
opposite cortical plate
and the structural and cellular
development of the organ
despite its immense cellular complexity
is actually based on simple principles
you have neural stem cells and
progenitors that proliferate in the
germinal centers they give rise to
neurons or differentiating glial cells
these cells then migrate out into the
particle plate
so if you were to sort of spatially
profile
uh this organ across the spatial axes
you end up revealing this uh basically
uh axes of cellular migration and
differentiation
in our experiments we initially used uh
wta profiling to examine bulk regions of
interest that correspond to different
compartments so the journal centers and
the cortical plate
this was a great piece of work done with
by a postdoc in my lab kenny roberts
with the
great support of robin frog from
nanostring
um when we did this we actually saw
really great qc results
in these regions of interest that i
highlighted in the middle in panel d
from as little as five cells we could
distinguish the expression of
at least 4 000 genes on an average many
of these rois that contain
a few thousand nuclei expressed eight to
ten thousand genes over limit of
detection
but today what i'd like to tell you is
very little biology and mostly focusing
on some of the tools
computational tools that we developed to
analyze this wta data
so the first tool is a probabilistic
generative model
that we call in situ cell tools or isu
for short
that estimates and corrects the
background binding
uh in the wta assay so
as most of you are probably aware wta
assay and you know the dsp assay uses
uh probes or antibodies to quantify the
expression of their targets
and when you have when you rely on
probes or antibodies you're going to be
dealing with a certain amount of
background
to be able to identify this alexander
ivy with this
who joins me for the panel today
actually developed this model
that tries to distinguish the biological
signal
that you see in the nanostring the real
signal
from the technical noise which comes
from both non-specific probe binding and
the sampling noise
the non-specific probe binding in this
isd model is estimated by the negative
wta probes
that can be used to measure such
background finding
and finally uh we were greatly
influenced in this model
by some recent work in deep generative
modeling or single cell data as shown in
this citation
so i'll jump right into the results
first what i'm showing you
is a good gene that contains very little
background that is effectively
verified by our isc model so what you're
looking on the left
is the expression profile of both
corrected
and uncorrected counts so in blue
you can see that this gene called stmn2
is highly enriched in cortical plates
stmm2 is a marker of neurons and we do
indeed expect to see
high expression at this gene at this
time point i hope you can appreciate
that with the
isc correction which is shown in red we
are effectively sparing this gene from
any kind of background reduction and we
are seeing the same pattern
conversely what you're looking at here
is now a bad gene with a lot of
high backgrounds this gene dlx1 is
actually a marker a
known marker of interneurons and when we
look into human fetal brain we expect to
see the expression of this gene
both in sort of the poles of the
germinal center as well as the cortical
plates
if you look at the raw counts here in
blue you see that in addition to the
dashed areas you see
lots of background binding in the middle
and what you have at isc
is the correction of this non-specific
background binding in the middle so in
red you're still maintained
the enriched expression of this gene in
the german centers as well as the
cortical plate
but you're not suffering from the
negative background binding in the
middle
and we indeed validate this with rna
scope which is shown on the right
so what does this background correction
actually do so
first it significantly increases the
number of genes that you detect from wta
and we would expect from cta analysis
but second it also significantly
improves the number of genes that you
detect from differential gene expression
analysis
so on the right uh we are actually
showing you
dc2 analysis of two different kinds of
aois corresponding to two different cell
types of the human fetal brain
that we profiled uh in this study and
when you compare these two different
cell types from wta data
you get a relatively small number of
genes about 200 genes that are different
if you were to use the background
corrected counts from isc
you see that a much higher number of
genes are detected and differentially
expressed
matching actually what we know about the
biology is these two cell types and
greatly improving the quality of the
data that we have
the second tool that i'll talk to you
about is
an extension of our efforts to integrate
single cell and spatial transcriptomic
data
uh to do this across multiple different
kinds of technologies
we've been working in the lab
collaborating with ole stegel at the
amble to generate a new probabilistic
model that we call
cell to location and what celta location
does
is that it can take a cell type
reference based on dissociative single
siren ac
which in this case was a published data
set of the human fetal brain
and it can decompose or if you prefer
that or
deconvolve bulk spatial transcriptomic
data like nanostring gmx wta
to give you the abundance of cell types
within the gmx data
and when we do this for the human fetal
brain
we see really nice uh basically
spatial identification of cell type
locations
shown here is the proportion of mrnas
from the wta data
that's uh our cell to location algorithm
attributes to d player neurons and if
you look at the spatial pattern
as shown on the right you see that
indeed these
deep layer neurons map to the cortical
plate where they're supposed to be
and this is work that we are quite
excited to share with the community soon
uh developed by a great graduate student
with colleagues chevnikov
so what we did is that we took sal to
location and we actually
uh with a great contributions from
alexander who is joining me today
we adapted it to account for technical
differences in the
between the wta data and single cell
data and we used it to basically map
single cell type references into wta
and i think the results were actually
quite spectacular uh
what i'm showing you here today is the
spatial locations of the 18 major cell
types that is identified in the single
cell data set
and the only little bit of biology i'll
tell you is that the spatial patterns of
these cell types
works really great if you were to look
at the germinal centers we indeed find
that different types of neural stem
cells are correctly mapped to the
different
parts of the germinal centers that
they're supposed to and if we were to
look into the spatial distribution of
neuronal differentiation
we also see a great pattern that
validates what we're supposed to see
in the blue box you can see that the
newborn neurons
abbreviated as xn are located in the
germinal centers
the migrating neurons abbreviated as xm
are
sort of transiting on their way to the
cortical plate and then the
differentiating
cortical neurons are much heavily
enriched in
the cortical plate xmu and xdp1 and on
top of this what we can see is that we
could take each of these cell types we
could cluster into many other sort of
detailed stratified subtypes
and we also get good information from
that
so with that i'll actually acknowledge
the labs alexander who developed the
both the isc and the south location wta
model that i talked about today
kenny who did the great work robin from
nanostring who was instrumental
in helping out with the nano singing
experiments as well as mitchely and oli
who worked on soft location
uh with that i will pass the baton to
janis flaccos from beth israel medical
center
and thank you
thank you omar so hello everyone from
boston
um before we start i wanted to mention
how excited i am to be
a part of this e-meeting with so many
amazing colleagues
sharing their work i wanted to first of
all to thank our hosts
uh for bringing everybody together my
group and i
are part of the beth israel deaconess
medical center harvard medical school
and the broad institute and in the
hopefully
10 minutes um i will try to share
experience from the integration of
special transcriptomics with single cell
technologies some of the challenges but
also
uh the tremendous transformative
potential of combining these two
modalities
so our group focuses on what we call
whole genome and beyond approach we're
trying to extract from a single patient
sample
the maximum amount of information and
integrated for basic
translational and precision medicine
applications
however the advent of two new
technologies really reshaped our
research program
of course uh you know single cell
techniques and this is the traditional
single cell smoothie figure
where enable us to go from bulk rna
sequence smoothies to single fruit
experiments
and of course you know location location
location
spatial transcriptomics enable us to put
you know expression on the map
understand how
localization tissue architecture and
morphology can affect
cellular transcriptional programs yeah
of course
the important part is that these two
technologies are exceptionally
complementary from single cell we get
you know the missing granularity
from uh the bulk techniques in and we
can
go beyond the literature we can uh
get our cell clusters and cell types on
a hypothesis free fashion
uh and continue from there what is
also interesting is that even though um
single cell techniques are rather
new i mean if we take the history of the
world
as a reference there are plenty of data
already
and methods uh available for folks to
work with
special transcriptomics are you know the
the cool new kid on the block
and enable us to to add architecture
and create expression maps localization
morphology
and understand how structure affects
function so we are utilizing
both as a single modality in our work
and we're trying to apply them on a
different set
of research questions uh for
the remaining uh eight minutes i will
try
to to to provide some high level
strategies and 30 000 foot overview but
also some of those nitty-gritty
um decisions that can really affect
downstream
outcomes i will use as a vehicle uh for
the rest of the presentation
um uh a data set on on liver we're
currently working on
so very briefly we have um core liver
human poor liver biopsies and we have
the frozen portion where we're um
subjecting it to snoop seek and we have
ffpe uh which are subjected to the very
cool
um whole transcriptome atlas on the
nanostring jmx
on the dsp platform where we get 20 000
genes
on the rois we select this is
an amazing new one c so in our
group uh we do not have only data
centric
labs as ours but we have also liver
specialists
uh we have experienced pathologists and
we in
a collaboration with nanostrength
scientists we were able
to capture and carve out really
informative new cool rois that capture
specific morphology features um donation
characteristics
uh and other uh liver
um features we wanted to analyze further
we aim for 16 rois per subject
and what is um quite interesting we put
two subjects per slide
for two main reasons one is convenience
of course
and the second um is also to be able to
assess
um batch effects and slight slight
variation
i will talk a little bit about that
because this is something we
are asked a lot for for liver
specifically more than any other tissue
we worked on and that could be
potentially how the samples were
prepared or for reasons and i'm known to
as
we see two important effects
happening one is uh we see
uh clear segregation from the slide to
slide so this is a a
plot showing four patients uh two ones
on one side and two on the other and
they clearly segregate based on the gene
expression per slide
but even if we zoom in uh to
just one slide we see them segregating
again within a smaller effect size
uh per patient of course this can be
patient patient variation it could be
biological
but its effect size is larger than the
morphology and zonation we would like
for instance to examine
so uh jared a brilliant computational
biologist from our group of course did
you know the first obvious thing he took
so here we plot only zone one two three
you know with brain orange and purple
and and you see that the segregation and
he modeled out
you know um slide and modeled out the
patient effect
um and you see for instance for the
patient you get a more homogeneous
um representation but however
you lose the signal of zonation
so he devised the method where you
rescue the biological
signal from known and unknown biases
and you continue working with the
residuals of that model
so on the bottom this is not new in
computational biology this has been
established by by jeff leakes group for
for many years now
um and in this adaptation of this
approach we see here the outcome uh so
these are the bssr
um residuals we're not working on
expression space anymore this is the
residual space
we can see that not only similar colored
rois uh huddle together but we
we keep this natural progression from
green orange
and to purple which is zone one two and
three
um so this is definitely very exciting
and we wanted to check
you know how does this affect the
biological signal so we see here
um two heat maps these are
genes in the literature that are
relevant to zonation in the liver and we
see for instance that in the bssr these
are the residuals these are the
normalized counts we're using as an
input uh
upper third quartile normalized counts
uh
from a lot of help from the nanostring
specialist so we can see the progression
from
central hepatocytes you know zone one
two three these are markers for um
portal hepatocytes again zone one two
three very gradual
decrease uh um peripheral and they'll
feel
uh very central on the field of cells
one two three and and peripheral
if you go to the original you see for
instance a mixed signal
and and that makes us first of all very
happy
that we are able to salvage the
biological this very refined biological
signal
um from for instance how the the slides
were prepared
and we use this residual space to all
our downstream analysis
um now this is where the the fun part
starts right
we have single cell experiments and from
the single cell
we don't need to use the markers that i
just showed that are from the literature
we can find
the actual clusters in the pathology
that we're uh studying
we can find sub clusters we can find
markers annotate them
uh do cellular trajectories and of
course you know
we can do also cell signaling
networks to to understand which cells
are talking to each other
but having spatial data really can
transform what we can do
because from the cell types that we have
identified in the markers
we can deconvolve and register them on
the rois
and that can enable us not only to
compare
you know the different zones and
different roi is using gene expression
but also cellular profiles
and can inform that that's why the
arrows
have have two edges and that can also
inform
the single cell we can compare zones in
the spatial
and check which cells are responsible in
the single cell
we can for instance answer the
fundamental question
i have this very interesting macrophage
population
uh in my single cell are those
macrophages in a specific region
all together are they scattered across
the tissue or are they in specific
sub-regions and if
yes what are those regions and what
other cells are there
and what is the the most transformative
aspect
at least in my opinion is that you
we did before and as everybody does
right you have your
um single cell and you do your signaling
network but you do not know whether
those cells are actually adjacent to
each other
you can create spatial aware signaling
where you can keep the populations you
get your ligands and receptors from the
single cell
and you create your network within their
life
um so
another thing that we tend to forget and
i
wanted to share this with you is that we
focus a lot on the expression space
um everybody does but we forget that
these are images and very informative uh
where we can
you know do image analysis count the
cells apply ai
connect gene expression with um
cellular morphology and cell counts
uh and we can also do you know image
analysis techniques
and so let me give you a simple example
so if we see the zonation in liver it
creates two-dimensional vectors
um that have you know different
orientation and different
lengths um but because we also
get you know the coordinate matrices for
their
eyes and the tissue uh we can apply
scale and rotation environment modeling
and that way we
can for instance model gene expression
as
far as distances from specific landmarks
regardless of scale
and orientation there are a lot of
things to to
to do on that image plus expression
space
i started with this slide and i wanted
to close because
um having both for us
has been a completely game changer we
get our cell types and our
subtypes from the single cell we get are
very specific for our pathology markers
we have seen a very big difference when
using for instance atlases from filthy
um tissues versus atlas as we create for
our specific pathology and applying them
on the on the spatial
we get our signaling relations and our
deconvolution reference
and then on the spatial we get you know
the architecture the map
um we can bounce cell populations in
space
and we can do spatially aware signaling
networks um so
our closing i i wanted to first of all
to mention that this
project that i briefly discussed is part
of an extensive effort
in the iemc uh this is um a group effort
among
eight pis um i wanted to shout out to
to my colleagues john g stephen win yuri
linus gordon and jonathan who are
part of this amazing initiative and of
course our lab members for helping with
the analysis
yard is spearheading um they set forth
but definitely nothing would have been
made possible you know if we didn't have
nanostrength
support to bring us close to this
technology
uh provide us access to experienced
engineers and scientists
and help us and guide us through this
process
to really maximize um the outcomes and
and the utility and the potential of
of our research so um please reach out
to us find us online
um uh find us on twitter uh we have
many fantastic things working in this
space and i'd be more than happy to take
any questions thank you
thank you giannis and thank you to all
our fantastic speakers that we've had
today
i wanted to open up and kick off the
panel discussion
uh we'll start with you young since we
just closed us out
and i wanted to talk to you a little bit
about the vision that you see
for where beth israel is going to take
these platforms in the near term and
maybe
what the long-term vision for
integrating
these different types of platforms would
look like to you
so yeah first of all that is a big
question to to be honest
and um so this is something we discussed
on two three different levels we
discussed it
you know with within the lab and our
colleagues on the hands-on
you know boots on the ground we but we
also discuss it with our
clinicians because it is a research
slash
academic slash clinical environment and
we also discuss it with our leadership
so my understanding is that
definitely for research this is
transformative
and i see a lot of colleagues they they
see our first results and they want to
test the water
they want you know since we're we
already have samples in the freezer and
we
already have ffbe blocks how can we
revolutionize how what we see and
increase granularity
but also um we are discussing with
um you know clinical trials and we're
discussing with
you know how can we bring this to inform
clinical decision making how can we
inform
the drug pipeline um i see within the
next let's say one or two years
definitely research will incorporate
more and more but within the next five i
see more trials
and i think and i hope that bi will be
spearheading this effort
absolutely i feel like that's one of the
reasons why we
start strive to have such a strong
relationship with your team because we
see you guys
actively working and developing towards
that
um i wanted to talk a little bit more
granularly about the near-term
needs that your research team has you've
talked a little bit about some of the
methods development and some of the
thoughts that you're putting in
in terms of using the spatial data
to inform some of the metrics that
you're getting out of single
cell data and do you have any thoughts
about
where that's going in the short term and
what methods need to be developed to
enable that more robustly
yeah so for us um that
that i do not know for sure because for
us this
is and for everybody working with these
new technologies especially the whole
transcription atlas
is new for everybody um
our first approach and i think this is
where
things are going is exactly to
understand
the commonalities and the differences
between existing modalities you know
it looks like rna-seq but it isn't you
know
how does that affect our model this is
very very simple it might sound very
simple
but if we want to make elegant modeling
understanding exactly
um you know the distributions the
limitations and how to incorporate
simple things you know the negatives
that you have
or so that is one thing maximizing the
information we can get from the raw data
is one
and the second is um can we do this
seamlessly can we map for instance do
transfer learning and can we
map our single cell with our spatial
data
um and integrate them very easily can we
anchor
the cells that we find what is the
limitation on the granularity for
instance for liver we have 52 clusters
um should we try to automatically map
them all
is there a level of granularity and
and then imputation methods can we use
the
spatial compute missing genes in our
these are
just low level practical things um and
these are the very short term i think we
can
dream bigger as soon as we we have those
sorted out
absolutely i i have one more question
for you
quickly um is in
in order to enable those types of
development efforts
around understanding the data types and
the data
methodologies what uh
critical holes in terms of access to
data do you see and what you'd mentioned
that there was
you know some potential roles for
developing atlasing efforts
do you see that playing a large role in
the short-term build that you need to be
able to then move
towards some of those longer-term goals
that you have yeah so
um i'll try to very quickly but this is
this actually has a lot of branches
we see this for instance in bi and we
i'm pretty sure that bi will be
spearheading this because
we have a share and open um
communication channel across the
institute and that
bringing more people more definitely is
a benefit especially for a new modernity
if we extrapolate this to the community
then yes
having and as i mentioned
it's not just the counts right so
for one range of applications i would
love to see
would be to maximize the utility of the
image data
at the same time you know use ai but you
need the images for that
you need the raw data for that you need
you need access to everything which will
usually not be part of a supplement um
so having access and being able to
compare
everything across groups i think it will
be transformative for the community
and that's how single cell actually
moved so quickly i mentioned in the
in the presentation that despite the
very few years we have a ton
of tools human cell atlas has been
instrumental for that
um if spatial moves towards the same
direction
i think it will get the mass and scale
very quickly as well
you so much and to kick off the panel
discussion i'd like to return to dr
chris mason
dr mason since you've been working with
the covet immune response atlas
i wanted to ask you a little bit about
how you're thinking about
with all the great data that you've
collected from other sources how you're
planning to integrate that
over time and what lessons each of the
data is telling you
uh in conjunction with each other
uh yeah great question no i think you
know the integration between
bulk data single cell and spatial
transcriptomic data
has been powerful to see but just in a
quantification level is one thing we
confirm
what we see for the presence of the
virus we can also confirm the host
response
what's happening this also the the very
least service of validation
but i also think if we can get you know
what we started doing is taking even the
spatial data
when we do any capture uh you know what
you get when you actually cleave is you
will get
information uh also what's present um
you know
some of the alleles that might be there
so we started to look at that as well
even things like a little specific
expression uh and also just looking at
the variance in the virus
started to do that as well the
integrations just started
uh across those modalities and has been
consistently hitting interferon
networks and also immune system stress
which you know unfortunately can lead to
some of the patients that we did the
autopsies on but
at least we can learn about what the
targets are in cells present for other
drugs that we could use to help them
fantastic and on a similar note
dr curtis i wanted to think with you or
hear from you
about how you're planning to take
the geomets data that you've got right
now and think about
from a translational perspective what
new data types and data sets you'd like
to be collecting
to augment the data that you have right
now as well as bruising out and building
out larger cohorts in future studies
sure yeah so i didn't get into the
details um given given the short
timeline but
um we've been really encouraged by how
well we've been able to resolve
differences at a proteomic and signaling
level
between responders and non-responders
and in fact
have shown that we can reliably predict
pcr and build a classifier to do that
which validates in an independent cohort
so we're pretty encouraged about
about the spiritual proteomic readouts
and as i alluded to
um there's signal there that we simply
don't see in the bulk
transcriptome so i think one of the next
steps that we're really excited to
to take is to leverage the cancer
transcriptone panel which has
matured considerably and is now um i
think would really allow us to go back
in and ask
you know whether the differences that we
observe are attributable to
the spatial context or if it is the more
proximal readout perhaps of looking at
the protein level
um so that's something that we're we're
really excited about and
um you know also seeking to incorporate
some single cell transcriptomic data
again
to map um in as much as possible
in an unbiased way what these
differences look like across therapy
and in your institutions approach are
you
are there any special considerations
that you're thinking about
while you're planning those studies sure
so we have a number of studies planned
both in in clinical cohorts um often
longitudinal cohorts
uh but also um you know retrospective
collections and i think
one of the key elements that were always
considering and paying attention to is
how we go about
sampling the tissue setting it up in a
way that we can really do
high-throughput studies so
um one aspect of that has that's been
essential is having a pathologist
involved really early on
um in many instances as we go forward
with larger cohorts
we're also embedding these tissues on
tissue microarrays
um so that we can ensure the
um sort of batch batch correction across
multiple samples from the same
individual but also just throughput lies
and i think one of the
um important findings that we've had is
that even with relatively small
core biopsies or core punches there's
we're capturing enough of the tumor
microenvironment
to um really delineate some of the
fundamental differences there and i
think
that's something that um you know up
until now wasn't totally understood how
deeply we need to sample
um so we paid a lot of attention to that
and we're also um you know in
collaboration with manastring thinking
carefully about
the um phenotypic and selection
strategies and how we can really harness
the dsp technology to um perhaps
delineate particular lineages before
going deeper with the the cancer
transcripton panel and the whole
transcriptome panels
thank you now that's great perspective
that you've offered there
you mentioned the role of pathologists
and
what they bring to the table while
you're doing and setting up the
experimental design
i know that dr mason was spending a lot
of
time and worked really closely with the
group pathologists at cornell
wheel during the experimental design for
the geomix
experiment would you mind talking a
little bit about that dr mason in terms
of what role they played and
how it informed the study design that
you had
yeah absolutely so i think this was a
real team effort uh
not just my lab at all and also uh you
know this is with
rob schwartz and also alain uh borsek
who's a pathologist here and
it's a really you know it's really
strange in the early days of
what could we do for the autopsies we
didn't know you know for example using
the bone saw
on the skull was not allowed because it
aerosolized too many components of of
the body so
uh autopsies had to be done very
carefully it was a lot that was unknown
in april and may as of what we could
even expect for
potential pathogenicity the virus
post-mortem but
uh dr borzer dr schwartz like really was
a team effort
of the three of us and also our labs all
working together and also getting
uh you know samples and bulk rna
sequencing and single cell
sequencing to match this so it was a
really really team effort and so i
really
uh represent all of our work here and it
was
a great example of staying uh in touch
with people who do the autopsies and
pathology work at your hospital because
you never know when you may need to uh
make a phone call uh to them and say hey
you know uh what what samples do we have
we should really look at this question
from a spatial perspective to complement
the rna other rna data we were getting
and yeah it's a great team effort
it's fantastic to hear um and i know
that some of the other members on the
call as well have been interacting
pretty closely with their pathology
so one of the things that stuck out to
me
omar and alexander with the wta data
that you were working through was that
you've been really thinking deeply about
the shape of the data and the type of
the data
that you're getting to work with i
wanted to ask you if you could provide a
little bit of content for some of the
analytical considerations that went into
building your model
and some of the concerns that people
might have when they're approaching
this new data type sort of a
high level answer that i can give is
that there's actually
um plenty of similarities that you can
find in how people approach single cell
data
and how you can approach wta data so
the analytical frameworks that we've
been using uh with the deep generative
models
you know assume that a negative binomial
distribution was a core part of
nanostring wta data
but when you think of a multi-spatial
scale data set like nanostring
where you can specifically profile
select cell types
uh in certain cases as few as five
styles or single cells
or you can profile much bigger balconies
where you have
uh you know thousands of cells much
higher numbers of transcripts much
higher number of genes
you're talking about really like a vast
distribution and what you found is that
flexible approaches might be required
you know sort of
alexander has had great success using
actually gamma distribution
when he was looking at really large rois
and really highly expressed genes
so um i think with wta and possibly with
cta
the analysis approaches how to account
the vast heterogeneity of different
types of spatial rois ai's that you can
do
when it comes to integration with the
single cell data
what we've noticed with wta and other
methods like vision slide sequencing etc
etc
is that uh and what the and others have
noticed is that uh
the platform specific effects are uh
a huge component and obstacle to proper
integration of the data sets
so you know if you basically took let's
just say that you processed
adjacent tissue sections with technique
1 and technique 2 you are going to end
up recording different quantities of
select genes and that will stem to merit
technical reasons of how the different
assays work and i think any kind of
integration tool that aims to
combine those data steps together has to
account and model those technical
differences
and doing sort of like bulk correlations
between different technologies like
singapore and wta
is always going to be error-prone at
some point
thanks for that particular background
and i completely appreciate that that's
a really critical part of validating
that
the data and the model that you're
setting up is valid and is going to give
you the context that you're interested
in
so i want to think from a
broader perspective about someone who's
coming into the field
with no real background in spatial
biology
and i wanted to talk through this with
each of you about
what your perspectives are that they
should know before they start doing
data analysis for spatial omics data
and how they should think about this as
being complementary or
a novel data set type that brings
different
perspectives to the field chris can we
start with you on that one
sure uh so i think there you know the
there are some tools already uh existing
in open source tools nano string has
tools on the computational side
that are the first thing to get familiar
with the other thing is it's like
anything in biology it's very exciting
to see such high resolution data
to really look at you know unparalleled
uh you know multiplex
uh tracing of you know thousands of
genes across
tissues but you yeah at the end of the
day the bedrock of good science is
replicates right so you need
you can't just do two or three uh slides
and be like okay good we're done
uh even though it's uh you know that is
deep and rich and complex and it's a
little bit expensive
uh you know you need to plan for a
proper experimental design which means
you know multiple samples with
validation
and replicates uh so it uh you know
you know i think those two the
computational and experimental design
features
uh are important but they are um things
that have been uh
established from other fields for a long
time so i had to get familiar with those
first
and then also some of the protocols and
also there's some customization you can
do with the probe so i think
if you have something unique you want to
do at least my experience been very
collaborative with nastering so you know
i'd say
for people that have a weird idea or
hypothesis something they want to look
for in a cell
you should ask because it's probably
something that's doable with it within
reason i guess i'd say
i can't speak on behalf of nanostring
but within reason yeah
don't try to be good partners on that
yeah yeah
christina what are your thoughts about
someone new coming into the field
and what they should expect from spatial
elements data
sure so i echo a lot of chris's
sentiments and i think that
um study design is crucial and thinking
through
you know it's great to have these new
tools but what is the hypothesis that
you're after what's the question
you know that you're seeking to address
and designing the study
accordingly is obviously key i think um
from a spatial perspective i mean it's
obviously important to do the
initial qc upfront on any data type that
you have to the extent that you have
orthogonal measurements that
that um you can corroborate findings
against i think that's that's quite
important too but obviously
um not always feasible um and i guess
the other point that i would just call
out is i think that you know now we're
beginning to have the capacity to look
both spatially
and temporally and and i guess i would
just hearken to the fact that i think
that the longitudinal
comparisons also call out some
additional um considerations and and
perhaps
um though to say that that with
spatially resolved approaches we're
mitigating some of the challenges that
we see when we're trying to compare
bulk populations you know ad mixed
populations through time
when there's changing um numbers
of cell types and so forth that are that
are hard to sort of pin down so i think
that
there's a real opportunity to harness
the spatial approaches as we think
um about time series data as it were
fantastic no i completely agree and
it'll be really interesting to see these
data sets evolve over time as more of
them come online
and become available to people
omar and alexander did you have any
perspectives that you wanted to share
on how your experience with manistering
wta data has evolved over time and what
lessons might be appropriate for
new people approaching this platform
i think alexander could take this one as
the person who
did work with wta data directly a
question
as somebody who was very experienced in
single cell
transcriptomic data analysis how did you
find that your
skills translate to wta data and do you
think you know being well worse than
single cell work makes you a better wta
analyst
or is it a completely different ballgame
obviously um it was in many ways
similar um i mean the whole structure of
the data it has a unique molecular
identifier so that's very
that's very useful that's similar to
think it's in an ac data
and then i mean the version we used had
the whole transcriptome
sort of information from the whole
transcriptome available so that's again
a little bit similar um so in terms of
the
models we were developing for this data
actually it was mainly the background
that was a little bit different
so in singles our next big data we have
this thing called soup
because cells can
can break up and we can get a bit of rna
from other cells
this is one type of background and
single cell and asic data and then in
wta data
um we have the background binding which
we need a slightly different
model for than the single cell rnase
data and then
the sensitivity was actually quite
comparable so that was great so
we find a similar number of genes
detected so often
most compared to most single silent
datasets
fantastic and
let me give a few more seconds there
since we didn't get a chance to talk to
you alexander earlier about your model
um when we cut off i'm gonna
phrase a question towards you and then
maybe you can jump back in on that
um so when you were working on building
your model
for analyzing the geomics wta data
what were some of the considerations and
background that you took from
other approaches that informed the model
that you developed
that you were working with with the wta
data
um yeah there was already quite a bit
available
people have thought for a while um
about um things like sampling noise that
we get from technology such as rna
sequencing also because
we never actually catch all the rna
whatever essay that we're using
and this process itself creates a little
bit of noise because we only capture
maybe one percent
five percent of the rna in the sale and
people have also thought about
generally how can we summarize the
expression of a cell biologically
using uh deep neural networks or using
something simple such as principle
component analysis factor analysis
so we could reuse these parts for
wta then
wta has negative probes available
this gave us some information about the
background binding which we need to
account for in
wta and then um wta
um yeah it doesn't have quite as many
um quite as many samples usually i mean
the typical experiments
as a single cell rna sequencing because
in single cell rna sequencing we can
sometimes have
millions of cells even sometimes a few
thousands
um so in a typical wta experiment maybe
we have information from 50 or 100
samples maybe soon more
and then you sort of need to adjust the
models a little bit so you don't
over fit the data and you need to make
slightly less
less complex models
great thanks for that perspective now
that's really uh really important to
keep in mind uh as this data has so much
uh ability to fit the type of model and
type of experiment that you want to do
um it has that flexibility in the roi
selection
that does bring up another point that i
wanted to pull the room a little bit
about
which was the role in which developing
uh broader access data sets might help
inform the community
and what role that there's that maybe
some of you
work on in terms of cross-institutional
consortia
might play in developing new resources
for the community
i know for example christina you're part
of h10
and i was interested in your perspective
on how the community might collaborate
in the future on these types of projects
sure so within h10 uh there's
which is the human tumor atlas network
there's been um
fairly extensive efforts to try and uh
generalize generate
orthogonal spatial and single cell
single cell resolution data sets on the
same material
as a means to inform the development of
analytic tools and
in some ways that's that's still
plugging along um
and i think that as we've heard from
from many of the speakers right
a big push going forward is really going
to be on the analytics and how we
interpret and leverage uh the most
information from these
um rich biological data sets i certainly
think that there's value
in establishing standards and best
practices both for
approach but also for the downstream
analytics and that of course takes time
you know we need to spend time with the
data to understand what's optimal and
this is still a very
um nascent field uh i also believe
though that
as you point out right having um
sufficiently representative cohorts that
have been profiled right
that allow us to understand the
composition topography of different cell
populations could be really valuable
um clearly there's going to be context
dependencies and i think in cancer
that's something we wrestle with
a lot there's the the tissue
dependencies there's the temporal
and the state of disease but i do think
having reference
data sets could help on many fronts um
in terms of moving the field forward
chris or omar anything you'd like to add
to that
all right i think some of the uh i guess
that's some of the things i'm also
looking for some of the
better measures of heterogeneity that
we're seeing themselves can be a metric
we've seen some of this from the bulk
field is that
heterogeneity itself epigenetically
especially can
indicate uh have a prognostic value in
indicated risk and so i think we'll
start to see this probably
also come out of the spatial data as
more jacksonville
great thank you all so much
i think this is we're getting pretty
close to time here for you so
i think we're going to wrap up our panel
discussion uh i want to thank
all of our speakers for the fantastic
conversation that we've had today
uh and i hope that this has been a
thought-provoking exploration
of the analytical needs and the future
for spatial
genomics to integrate with the
analytical toolkits
that people have available for their
next waves of scientific exploration
in addition to the great work described
by the panelists here today
i'd like to point out that nanastring is
excited to announce the launch of
geomet's translational leadership
network the gtln
which is aimed at again helping develop
some of these shared resources
tools and facilitating conversations
across
large institutions and has been
working with breast cancer researchers
in one case as well as covid
researchers in another case we are now
starting to take applications for new
members
to build future consortia in oncology
immunology and neuroscience
spanning the realms of discovery science
as well as translational and clinical
applications
applications can be found on our website
manustring.com
and stay tuned for more gtln updates or
please contact uh geomics at
manastring.com to learn more about
geomix dsp
or gtln thank you all again for the
fantastic conversation today
and for your participation